[Music]
this year PC gamers have experienced the
new multiplayer phenomenon and player
unknowns battlegrounds there have also
been a few exclusives like Dawn of War 3
and rising storm 2 and 2 console
classics Bayonetta and vanquish hit the
PC this year in all their glory but
while those games have shined in their
own respect plenty of great games may
have flown under your radar so let's
roll through a few of our favorite games
on PC that you might have missed this
year and as always subscribe to our
channel here at GameSpot for all your
gaming coverage there been plenty of
super tough platformers in the vein of
2010 Super Meat Boy and like many of
them super ood bear resurrection is
happy to kill you over and over again
but it also gives your deaths of purpose
whenever you die you leave behind a
corpse which essentially serves to make
a given level easier it might block a
laser from hitting you cover up a set of
deadly spikes or give you a boost to
make it jump easier for an extra
challenge you're free to play without
the assistance of these corpses though
doing so will cause you to miss out on
some fun opportunities to see how they
can modify a level the game also
provides a steady stream of new
adversaries and mechanics from beginning
to end the sense of satisfaction it
provides when you're able to make it
through a particularly difficult section
is incredible
as a love letter to 90s first-person
shooters straped captures the frantic
pace and thrills of its reference
material from the retro visuals and
blocky blood splattering to the variety
of weapons and abundance of Secrets
stripe is still worth playing even after
the campaign's final encounter if you
ever make it that far
each run is a thrill as you violently
dance through the game's tall
procedurally generated levels and the
roguelike structure heightens the stakes
as you get further along strafe has its
own unique charm with comical
self-awareness and silly yet threatening
enemies but the soundtrack weaves all
the game's elements together to elevate
the experience beyond the standard
first-person shooter each level has its
own synthol an electronic rock track
that instills a sense of wonder inspires
you to fight through the hordes or
intensifies the feelings of danger or
often makes you feel all these things at
once
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine a relatively quiet town in the
American Midwest populated by
anthropomorphic animals that's possum
Springs we're not in the woods takes
place and as May a cat human you
experience a readjustment to your
hometown after getting the boot from
college this comes in the form of a
side-scrolling adventure where
conversations character interactions and
minigames propel you through a
complicated and emotional tale of modern
young adulthood
every story beef hidden tidbit line of
dialogue and optional interaction
encourages exploring the beautifully
painted world of night in the woods the
game isn't for everyone but it hits
exactly what it aims for through the
uniquely charming artwork and quirky yet
emotive soundtrack the poignant
storytelling is wrapped in elements to
elevate it above many games this year
dream daddy at that dating simulator is
a visual novel published by the game
grumps in which you play as a dad who
romances other dads in your own town it
became an instant hit among dating sim
fans when it was released in July but
even if you don't really consider
yourself the type to date dads you got
to give it a shot it's filled with puns
and dad jokes but at its core there's an
incredibly heartwarming story about
raising a daughter on your own it's also
inclusive without feeling like the
diversity is just posturing sexuality
and gender issues are presented
effortlessly but for the most part the
dad's narrative arcs are focused on
fatherhood in that sense dream daddy is
widely relatable
[Music]
what remains of Edith Finch is a game in
the same vein as dear Esther and gone
home and it tells a hauntingly beautiful
tale through the generations as suppose
it cursed leads every family member to
die in unexpected and bizarre ways as
Edith Finch you explore the huge
mysterious family manner in which
gameplay vignettes unearth how your
relatives spent their last moments the
story is cryptic gripping and dark it's
full of unexpected twists and turns and
could only effectively be told through a
videogame considering you could beat it
under three hours there's little reason
to wait before playing
graceful explosion machine falls into
the category of frantic 2d spaceship
shooters but it's not quite the bullet
hell experience there aren't any dense
curtains of seemingly unavoidable
projectiles here rather than waiting for
wave after wave of enemies to come your
way you pilot a cute little spaceship
through corridors and face off against
swarms of enemies using both traditional
laser cannons and a small but varied
selection of special weapons dashing
through groups of enemies is an
empowering and useful tactic that calls
back to the feeling of resogun the trick
to graceful explosion machine is to
quickly juggle your various weapons
while also boosting through the groups
of increasingly stronger enemies and
whatsits under your skin the dance is an
adrenaline rush fight to survive and to
climb the leaderboards these are just a
few of the gems we've played on PC this
year so check out our written feature on
gamespot.com for all the games that we
highlighted what's your favorite PC game
this year that should get more love if
you got something to say hit up the
comments give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to our channel you know the
deal and don't forget to watch our other
videos on the best games that you might
have missed on ps4 switch and Xbox one